with Ryan shazier in the hospital right
now who better to have on from the mm QB
Albert Priya here on the show how you
doing Albert
I'm good rich too bad I didn't hear from
you last week kind of I guess waiting
time takes the edge off a little bit
doesn't it edge off of what the edge off
of the edge off of your third straight
or your sixth straight loss well I
thought you almost said third string
since that's the quarterback that we had
again look man you're the better team I
don't have a problem admitting that it's
tough obviously for me to swallow I
can't I cannot believe all my michigan
friends have been going back and forth
14 out of 15 it's just it is it boggles
the mind but at some point it's gonna
have to change one has to think and one
of the reasons why I did ring you up is
because I'm sure you know all about
jay-z or what what can tell about folks
about jay-z or who he is and the parents
that just got flown in private charter
by the Steelers to check on him and what
you know about his condition yeah you
know I I think when when when urban got
to Ohio State he was really sort of one
of the foundation pieces and one of the
more well like some guys in the program
and here's one thing that really sticks
out about him
if you if you go back and you anybody go
on youtube and call his Ohio State
highlights you'll notice he's wearing
three different numbers you know and
some of them he's wearing the number 48
in others he's wearing the number two
and then you know most of them he's
wearing his number which is which was
number ten and you know where you come
to find out if you research that is the
wor 48 for guy he grew up with that home
who'd passed away and then he wore
number two because one of Ohio State's
captains that year broke his leg him
without a year and so you know it's that
doesn't make him a hero but you know
he's just kind of like one of these guys
he's really conscientious about the
people around him and really cares about
the people around him and you know I
think that's why he was such a good
natural leader with Ohio high a state
during transition from Luke sickle to to
Urban Meyer and then you know again kind
of became leader of the new group the
new young group did that they're
building in Pittsburgh on the defensive
side of the ball
you know and they've got a lot of good
young players there and you know he was
sort of the guy who I think was going to
be you know your you know like that
LaVon Kirkland Lawrence Timmons guy in
the middle of defense for years to come
and so you know I I know we always say
these things in the wake of of stuff
like this but it really is genuinely his
reputation couldn't be much better and
that goes all the way back to when he
was 18 19 years old in college and so do
we know anything more about his
condition as we're currently sitting
here in the middle of look it doesn't
look good I know there's been some
feeling in his extremities but you know
I I think we have to wait and see and
and and more information will come out
on this but you know clearly he's not
out of the woods knew you're right I
mean for a team that you know is all
about the offense throne and around for
an organization that used to be about
running the ball with Bettis and then
that defense right and then that defense
that LeBeau is cooking up all sorts of
evil and then they lost Polamalu and
they lost everybody that used to be
associated with that you know it's
interesting that shazier is definitely
he's definitely become the leader of
that yeah and you know it's it's it took
him a while to I mean this is probably
as well-rounded miss Tomlin's had since
lost em in Super Bowl right in 2010 they
become offense heavy because they got
old on defense and a bunch of those guys
were gone and they didn't do a great job
of replacing them at first I'm talking
about the guys like Polamalu you know
lowness Timmons was there for a little
longer but Ike Taylor you know they it
took him a while to build that back up
and now it looks that they're finally
they're rich you know behind guys like
Ken Hayward Stephon to it and TJ watt
bud Dupree and already burns it looks
like they're finally getting there you
know and and really I think the way that
they envisioned it was after this year
they were going to launch a 0 give him a
big contract and he was going to be the
leader of the next generation of great
steal or defenses and so obviously all
that's up in the air now and they're
more important matters at hand or
certainly he was sort of the face of the
the rebuild that Kevin
Aubert mike tomlin had successfully
pulled off a couple of years rebuild
from some of the great players on that
defense that one of whom you neglected
to mention Lamar Woodley I wonder wildly
out of that next now I like Lamar Lamar
Woodley he's no slouch
alright so what what happened what can
you say happened with Ben McAdoo
obviously the losses are one thing but
wasn't he just carrying down the message
from the owner through Jerry Reese that
was intended which is Eli you're sitting
yeah you know that part of it
you know certainly and and I think well
over the years we've seen this with John
Mara they have they have largely those
owners have largely left the football
decisions to the football people and
empower the football people to make
those decisions the general managers and
the coaches that they've had there you
know I I think one of the early bad
signs was the week of the Beckham dog
being thing you know and and I think Ben
had made an effort to set a standard
with his team by going at Eli after that
Monday night and kind of trying to send
the message to his team nobody's above
on the standard here and six days later
the dog king thing happens and Ben came
after that game and said well you know I
wish everybody would focus on the great
catches he was making three days later
John Mara is sitting Odell Beckham down
and the fact that he had to do that but
the head coach hadn't accomplished what
needed to be accomplished there I think
was the first sign of real doom and you
know we saw it again in this situation
where John Mara had to come down and
kind of massage the situation after all
hell broke loose early last week and I
think it was just kind of you know those
are signs along the way that well done
McAdoo is a good coach he's maybe not
the program leader that they needed
there and that's one of the things that
gets lost sometimes rich you know a lot
of times you want to bring in a coach
you can develop quarterbacks you want to
bring in a coach you can call in offense
and you forget that you know these guys
are really the CEO of the football
operation you know they're the guys in
front of those 53 guys and they're in
charge of those 53 guys and they're in
charge of all those coaches and that's
biggest part of their job and I think
that's the part of the job where been
really failed and you can see it was his
handling of Odell Beckham and you could
certainly see it with the way that the
Eli Manning thing unfolded over the last
week so who's next who do you think
they're gonna target well I think until
we know who the general manager is we
may not have a clear idea of that I
certainly think that you know you can
look to the Patriots organization
because I know this I know John Mayer is
gonna place that call to Bill Belichick
and he's gonna ask Bill Belichick what
he thinks and I would think Bill
Belichick would vouch for both Nick
Kesari oh and Josh McDaniels and so I
think the possibility of a package deal
is there I also think you could pair
Josh with somebody like Scott Pioli
in Atlanta or even a Eric decosta you
know in Baltimore who's been kind of a
hands-off guy because you know everybody
assumes he's just gonna succeed
Ozzie there I think Eric would be
somebody who could be in play because
this is a Cadillac job maybe that'd be
the job that he'd actually leave
Baltimore floor and so I think you've to
identify who the GM is going to be first
I think one thing that the Giants have
to look at to hear and this is an
important piece of it is do we look at
restructuring our organization forever
there it's been the Ted coach works for
the GM in fact going all the way back
that's what caused friction between
George Young and Bill Parcells and so I
think that they have to look at the idea
maybe of dividing the power and a little
bit of a different way because it that
that might be what it takes to get the
right head coach and if you look in
certain situations that is what it takes
to get a great head coach Dan Quinn was
in command in demand three years ago so
the power over the 53 same thing with
Adam GaSe in Miami two years ago and so
I think not only do they have to look at
these individual names for both those
spots I think they also have to look at
how the football operations set up and
so there's a there's a lot of big
decisions to make and it's not just on
which people are in charge it's also on
how do we want to set this whole thing
up because that could affect who's
available to them Bert love chatting
with you will chat down the line okay
all right thanks rich have a good one
got a salver career of the mmq began
check out his column on the Giants the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience